now I'm a big curry fan but there's a
lot more to Indian cooking than just
clothes alone so tonight I'm going back
to the floor to learn how to cook good
tandoori food I've come to South all in
West London an epicenter of Asian
cuisine
I'll be working at the brilliant one of
his busiest restaurants will be serving
more than 150 covers in just three hours
time so the pressures on said that
that's just when Lizzy yes I'm heading
down the ranks under the critical eye of
head chef jazz and big boss Gullu
so where am i working you've been
working right here on the clay oven and
that gets up to what temperature that
gets up to roundabout 440 degrees yeah
Jesus the clay oven or tandoor is where
all the tandoor dishes are made I have
given Gordon the hardest jobs in the
kitchen that to handle clear oven and
that's your naan bread you see kebabs 10
Duty chickens your tandoori lamb chops
let's see how it gets on my first lesson
is making lamb psyche Babs one of the
most popular starters on the menu
nice C cube abs are made with lamb mince
and 20 different spices
is it gonna michalis without chili
Porter's your Hambrick porters this is
chops onions to court a nice once the
meats been seasoned I have to get it
onto the skewer Jesus yeah
one thing that will like this Sunil made
this look easy push squeeze on finger
out cuz thank you that thing about you
need a practice man all right Co mob is
ready sir
that's it ready sir mine's bigger than
yours it doesn't matter does it
H tandoor can cook 20 skills of meat or
fish at a time at 400 degrees everything
cooks in minutes I thought I had
asbestos hands after 20 years in the
kitchen but these skewers are red-hot oh
[ __ ]
okay that's hot what's your hands are
okay that's height so no tongs no gloves
and that's one portion that's taking me
ten minutes yeah
naan breads are also cooked here Sunil
makes it look really simple so I'm
feeling more confident that's here
perfect naan bread there are five
varieties each roll shaped and then
cooked on the inside of the oven
that's why is it hot yeah they take just
one minute to cook before they're peeled
from the oven and served it's ticking
like [ __ ] to a blanket ah hello
Oh bollocks ah [ __ ] [ __ ] ass too hot
look it looks like be mauled by a
Rottweiler you can do like 14 breads
naan breads in one go I'm struggling
with 140 not I'm so bad at this it's
embarrassing
I'd better get a grip before service
starts or I'll be letting everyone down
as long as he listens to me what I need
from him we won't have any kind of
problems I think the [ __ ] vindaloo is
gonna hit the fan